I'm here with Jesse Ro, whose a math teacher at Summit San Jose
and a Khan Academy teaching fellow
and you had some interesting ideas or questions.
Yeah, one question that students ask a lot when they start Algebra
is why do we need letters, why can't we just use numbers for everything?
Why letters? So why do we have all these
Xs and Ys and Zs and ABCs when we start dealing with Algebra?
Yeah, exactly.
That's interesting, well why don't we let people think about that for a second.
So Sal, how would you answer this question?
Why do we need letters in Algebra?
So why letters. So there are a couple of ways I'd think about it.
One is if you have an unknown.
So if I were to write X plus three is equal to ten
the reason why we're doing this is that we don't know what X is
It's literally an unknown.
And so we're going to solve for it in some way.
But it did not have to be the letter X.
We could have literally written blank plus three is equal to ten.
Or we could have written Question Mark plus three is equal to ten.
So it didn't have to be letters, but we needed some type of symbol.
It literally could've been Smiley Face plus three is equal to ten.
But until you know it, you need some type of a symbol to represent whatever that number is.
Now we can go and solve this equation and then know what that symbol represents.
But if we knew it ahead of time, it wouldn't be an unknown.
It wouldn't be something that we didn't know.
So that's one reason why I would use letters
and where just numbers by itself wouldn't be helpful.
The other is when you're describing relationships between numbers.
So I could do something like - I could say - that
whenever you give me a three, I'm going to give you a four.
And I could say, if you give me a five, I'm going to give you a six.
And i could keep going on and on forever.
If you give me a 7.1, I'm going to give you an 8.1.
And I could keep listing this on and on forever.
Maybe you could give me any number, and I could tell you what I'm going to give you.
But I would obviously run out of space and time if I were to list all of them.
And we could do that much more elegantly if we used letters to describe the relationship.
Maybe what you give me we call X, and what I give you we call Y.
And so I say, look, whatever you give me, I'm going to add one to it.
And that's what I'm going to give back to you.
And so now, this very simple equation here
can describe an infinite number of relationships between X
or an infinite number of corresponding Ys and Xs.
So now someone knows whatever X you give me
you give me three, I add one to it, and I'm going to give you four.
You give me 7.1, I'm going to add one to it and give you 8.1.
So there is no more elegant way that you could've done it than by using symbols.
With that said, I didn't have to use Xs and Ys.
This is just a convention that kind of comes to use from history.
I could've defined what you give me as Star
and what I give you as Smiley Face
and this also would've been a valid way to express this.
So the letters are really just symbols. Nothing more.